-Welcome back, everybody.
Thank you for watching
"The Tonight Show."
I'm about to show you some books
that you should avoid
at all costs.
It's time
for the latest installment of my
Do Not Read list.
Here we go.
♪ Do not read, do not read ♪
♪ Do not read these books,
these books ♪
-Now, before we start,
I just want you to know
that every book that I'm about
to show you is 100% real.
These are actual books that
you can find them on Amazon
or check them out
at your local library.
They are real.
All right, let's see what's on
my Do Not Read list.
This first one is a joke book.
-Oh, great.
Love jokes.
-Yeah, that's right up my alley.
This one's called
"The Humour of Germany."
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's a hilarious cover.
Already, the cover's funny.
-Yeah.
What year was --
I just want to know
what year that's from.
[ Laughter ]
-They have some classics
in here.
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah, here.
How about this classic
right here?
A chapter -- "The Incarceration
of Herr Professor."
[ Laughter ]
Sounds hilarious.
I'll give it a read.
-[ German accent ] It's funny!
[ Laughter ]
-Next up is a cookbook.
-[ Normal voice ]
Oh, I love cookbooks.
-I have a great collection
of cookbooks.
-You do?
-Yeah.
This one is
"500 Tasty Sandwich Recipes."
-Mmm.
-Look at how tasty
that one looks.
[ Laughter and groans ]
-Oh!
Wow!
What?
That's a sandwich?
-A good asparagus sandwich.
-Mmm!
-Open face.
-Oh, put it in the toaster oven.
-Name what sandwich that is.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. The pimento loaf --
-There's a surprise at the end.
[ Laughter ]
What do they have in here?
-It's called da laundry lint.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
Look at this.
They have
ham and peanut butter sandwich.
-Oh.
-Ham and raisin.
Pot--
Potted meat.
-Ugh.
[ Laughter ]
Mmm, tasty!
-That's pretty good.
Potted meat, yeah.
Next up is an activity book
for kids.
-Oh, great.
-It's called "101 Things
for Girls To Do."
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-I have girls.
This might be great for them.
-What can they do?
-Let's see what they can do.
How to sharpen scissors.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
And then run with them.
-Yeah.
There's other things to do.
Next up is a travel book.
-Oh, I love travel.
-A lot of people are looking
forward to just
getting out there traveling,
people who are looking
to take the family road trip.
Check this out here.
This is called
"Nuclear Heartland:
A guide to the 1,000
Missile Silos
of the United States."
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
I can't wait.
-Let's take a look inside here.
This one says,
"A Family Outing," here.
It says, "A Family Outing."
"We sat, my wife, our three
children, myself, and our dog.
A few hundred feet away
was a Minuteman missile
tipped with a warhead
containing an explosive force
of 1.2 million tons of TNT.
It hummed during the night."
[ Laughter ]
Sounds like a dream family vac--
You won't forget
that vacation too soon.
-No, it'll be -- every time
the child closes his eyes,
he'll remember that vacation.
[ Laughter ]
"Why am I radioactive?"
-All right.
Next is a cookbook called
"Cooking with Coke."
-Oh, is it by Don Jr.?
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's --
♪♪
-Coca-Cola.
No, the soft --
"Cooking with --"
"Cooking with Coke."
Yeah, here we go.
"Cooking with Coca-Cola."
-Coca-Cola, okay.
-"Cooking with Coke."
-My mistake.
-I feel like
a real Peter Douchey.
-Here's a, uh --
[ Laughter ]
-Doocy.
-Doocy, sorry.
Here's a recipe.
Here's sweet and spicy
shrimp tacos with mango salsa.
-Mmm.
-Uh, I don't know about
the mango salsa.
I don't want
the mango overpowering
the shrimp and Coke.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause that's just a combo.
-Yeah.
-That's up there with, like,
ham and raisins.
-Yeah, I love ham, raisins,
and Coke.
-We're down to our last book.
It's a self-help book.
-Oh, I love self-help.
-Yeah.
This is called "A Guided
Meditation for Beginners."
-Oh, that's great.
-We could all use this
right now.
-Yeah.
-Let's see what tips
they have for us here.
-Okay. What's page one?
-Here we go.
This first page says, "Inhale."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Next one says, "Exhale."
-It's the whole book.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's all the time we have
for "Do Not Read."
If you have a book you think
should be on our next
"Do Not Read" list,
send your title to
donotread@tonightshow.com.